so you're just finishing up this tour
with the Eagles yeah I've got two more
weekends yeah have any how do you feel
about that well it's pretty surreal you
know I couldn't be more grateful that
they thought of me to come and do that
you know but I'm only getting to do it
because of something sad that happened
with the passing of Glenn and and I I
had their first record I don't want to
hear anybody but Glenn sing those songs
either you know I know there was a
little bit of blowback from some fans
and stuff Weiss a country guy coming in
there and this and that and I think a
lot of that has dissipated over the last
three years and I think it's a really
really really great fit mmm I think what
I do and what I've learned to do a lot
of it was from them
you know I've got tapes took me a lot of
courage to play the tapes of me at 15
years old singing peaceful easy feeling
but it was horrible and we all had a
nice laugh I said you never heard that
you'd never hired me yeah would you keep
doing it
absolutely what do they want
I mean it's you know like I said it's
it's a the opportunity to sing the best
songs yeah then if to me have ever come
down the pike and in an American band
you signed up originally for two dates
right yeah something like that I mean
they wanted to figure it out too it was
I'm sure it was you know just
excruciating for them to think about
moving on without Glennon as it has as
it should be you know and not sure they
wanted to do it so I think it was more
of let's just try this and see how it
works and and it went okay you know and
I think you know it's funny I can even
feel it from the crowd every time when I
get in front of their crowd I could feel
this there's kind of holding your breath
when I'd start singing yeah it's like oh
it's not the guy it's not the guy I'm
used to and then after after a couple of
verses of this and that I could just
literally see them just go it's gonna be
okay yeah you know so it was it was it
was a great feeling you know to be
nervous
then see ya see it all kinda go well
okay that's gonna be alright we're gonna
trust you with this
yeah maybe and they're still you know
can I have a lot of folks that say no
Glen no Eagles you know and that's fair
you know they can feel that way if they
want